so today we're going to do a little bit
of a tactic session a docked accession
is basically what Grand Master's do when
they want to sharpen their brakes so
people always come up to me and they ask
hey you know how are you seeing eight
nine moves ahead I can barely see too
well you practice I mean it's not like
one day I woke up and it was like wow I
can see somebody moves ahead this is
awesome you know maybe I'll learn French
tomorrow
no like you have you practice you
practice hard and eventually you get the
ideas now how do you practice well
there's several ways tactics are divided
into several sections that means the
most popular of them all or what we call
chess calm or chess tempo type tactics
which are these two three movers you
solve them in less than a minute you
move on right these are very basic
tactics and these are very basic tactics
that are the building blocks for more
important more actual chess kind of
tactics which you can calculate from a
little bit further away so all these
building blocks that you see in chess
that come are awesome because if you're
really sharp at seeing double the tax
then you're never going to miss a double
attack in your life but the chess
unfortunately is made of more than just
double attacks so what happens when we
need to actually sharpen your brain to
something a little bit stronger you need
a little bit better whetstone than just
a simple Internet
one minute to minute tactics and so we
come to the fabulous world of difficult
tactics and compositions so the first
thing we're going to start with is a
concept called a composition yes it's an
artificial problem it's composed exactly
so composers in chess have existed for a
very long time and basically what it is
is players that specialize you're
creating aesthetically pleasing
solutions to difficult problems so they
set up the problems that have some kind
of aesthetically pleasing solution this
is a very simple composition
compositions range from very pretty to
and very simple to kind of murky and
complex to absolutely gorgeous and very
complex today we're not going to see
anything too fancy we're not going to
see any of those that are well that you
could say like wow this is impossible to
have ever come to a game then we're
going to see a couple that are like a
you know this might have happened that's
not so far from the expected world of
chess and in this case we're going to
start with a with a composition by Pogo
science and in this case white is to
move every composition is the same thing
why just a move and they have an
objective either it is to win or to draw
obviously in this case it's not to draw
because I can just draw with my eyes
closed right so I have to find a way to
win but the way to win is not trivial
every time and compositions there will
be only one way to win if it's - it's a
bad composition it'll probably not get
published anywhere and certainly no
grandmaster will be giving it to you 50
years later so this one obviously only
has one solution which makes this so
interesting so white is to play and win
so the first thing when we do when we're
calculating is the first thing you do
when you calculate first thing
you list your candidate moves excellent
so the cabinet moves are the first thing
you have to look at so here we can just
get rid of several kind of easily and
some of them not so easily so all right
what are some Candida moves in this
position
I'll despite the simplicity of it and
now they're not being so many pieces
there are a lot of moves that can be
considered on the first try so ideas
doesn't have to be a good idea just to
be an idea that's how chess works you
start off with an idea it might be a
terrible idea but you start from
somewhere can you have sick all right
excellent
that is refute this immediately can you
have 6 if pawn takes c6 if you take with
the pawn I take with the bishop on its
Emelia draw right just last time I
remember you cannot make it with a lone
night and if Knight takes c6 then Bishop
h7 in essence traps your pawn right so
there is no hope of this ever making
progress what else as a candidate move
sorry so nigh g6 is possible with the
idea I guess that if you take on g6 King
g6 right Oh King f6 with the idea of
pushing the pawn that's quite
interesting so this and if you take this
Queens why not because King D 7 yeah and
now the King protects the winning square
not so clear all right it was
interesting but not sufficient 1 of 6 so
ok we have point of 627 immediately
winning yes but after pawn takes you
have to somehow get rid of this Bishop
right defending the f7 square so let's
say you go forward just for example
right then I go e 5 you go forward and
I'm going to keep the bishop on this
diagonal and you cannot really interpose
this night between the bishop at the
pawn technique for progress not to
mention that this part is kind of
running right it's not so easy for me to
stop it so this is definitely not
winning f6 does not work I try but not
good enough for Texas so context f7 rose
into the problem that this is a draw you
don't have enough control over the
diagonal to ever force this Bishop off
of it and this will be a very easy draw
the pawn can only go as far as f6
without the bishop forcing it sacrifice
on it on on f7 square so now good enough
kh6 already we have the idea bringing
the king yes so ah we don't have too
many choices with black and fortunately
for white pawn takes is sufficient I
cannot recapture because the simple
recapture will be a draw I cannot play
King g7 because I take on a5 so f6
is the only try but again the idea of
'if I've saves the bishop from the g8
trap mint and it's a draw yeah
hiiiiii
now what
are we out of Candida news
so we have e7 but okay of course you're
quitting so I have to take it now your
Knights trapped
well okay now we're just kind of
throwing things out there right without
really I mean the king going back can
certainly not be the way to go although
these are usually unusually aesthetic
aesthetically pleasing solutions they
also kind of make sense in some sense in
some way of seeing it the king going
back to f4 of course okay that's very
little for me well I would love to but
that night is yeah but we went through
night g6 I think we already took on e6
and push d5 yeah and I think even I can
take the port the night in that
variation specifically yes I should be
able to so not good we're out of ideas
are we officially out of ideas so these
are the kind of puzzles that
grandmasters kind of love to solve it
forces us to think outside of the box
outside the box that's impression yeah
outside the box because it's very easy
to see a book that says this is the
double attack section and then you go
through the section and you find every
single double attack there is in the
book because you're looking for every
single double attack that there is and
that's not so useful for your tactics
because what happens in the real game of
chess is that nobody comes up to your
board and says hey hey you that that's a
double attack you know there's this one
find it you know you're most time was
the time gonna have to do it for
yourself in this case we use an idea
called zoogs one all right the correct
move in this position is actually e
seven kind of unusual why give up the
pawn black does have to take this pawn
because if you go f6 I simply capture it
and you cannot stop it right so you must
take another correct movies have six
check oh but that blood is the knight
yes so Kim takes f8 and a an idea called
domination
Misha page 7 does not help blacks
position Kimmie 8 king g7 King bee 7
takes King e6 and just by 110 per kg 7
zoogs org and black will be forced to
relinquish his last remaining upon and
the pawn end game is quite lost
interestingly the bishop on g7 never
played a role in the game it only played
a role because you let it play a role
but it makes some sense in some cases to
simply shut out the bishop in this case
the full solution is actually e 7 takes
f6 kingi 8 and now can somebody guess
whites move not guess calculate what am
I say
probably teenage six is that after King
takes a fate what am I going to play not
so easy yes now the bishop goes out now
black wins
ah so King age five if you lose a temple
on purpose now the bishop cannot move
because I capture it
if you pull King f8 you just transpose
back into the position and if you go
King d8 your king is too far from the
night so white wins alright not that
hard right let us see another one oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah here you're going to
be given a full extra two rooks against
only two miserable pawns but it just
happens that both of these pawns are
queening and you have to figure out a
way to stop both of them for you to win
or if you don't stop them at least do
something so dangerous to black that he
is not going to be able to save himself
two rooks are very powerful pieces and
people tend to underestimate how easily
they can weave innate a mating net so
immediately we kind of run into a little
bit of a more forced position in the
previous one in the first move there are
not that many alternatives if I play
route b3 he Queens if I play route
either to d3 he Queens again and the
Queen versus to rook endgame under most
scenarios I mean with exceptions is a
draw I mean there shouldn't be any
reusing the two rooks cannot play a
queen so what to do what to do in chest
first we need to consider what kind of
moves huh candolyn was okay but let's go
back even more beginner than that so
your chess coach is coming to your house
you're 1,000 and he tells you well you
should have considered this move because
first types of moves that you think of
our checks and captures you cannot
capture anything in this position so the
first thing you should be thinking about
is a check okay three checks must be the
move there's no other way to stop the
pawns right but what then he plays King
before it looks normal right now I
cannot still stop the pawns so maybe I
should check again Group III okay
not now black now has some problems if
you were for example to play a king a5
immediately rook h8 will be with you
because now he's in a mating net yes
everybody see that if you play King a4 I
take on b2 we ignite the mating thread
and then I'm also trying to take your
pot and d2 right so you cannot play King
a5 that's the worst of all so if King a
for this one runs in - oh yo what now
the problem is Brook ht3 is that after
Queen takes takes this king is so close
to the remaining pawn that it's going to
cost your rook so it's still a draw
obviously this position I'm not trying
to draw with what I can do that again
with my eyes closed we could more checks
but at this point we kind of run out of
ideas because I play okay three check he
just goes back to before we already
analyze this position so now comes the
creativity of a grandmaster you are not
going to try to stop the pawns anymore
try to weave a mating net so you want to
play this one where
absolutely correct
if black stays still the thread is
simply route g1 right and after route g1
there is still no hope this route keeps
the king out and all I have to do is
bring my king over and take all the
ports
he must Queen one of the points
interestingly enough it does not matter
which one so let us try the one
check check check check
and one time four to five for the king
checkmate if at some point the Queen
interposes then I have transposed into a
variation in which the king is too far
away from the point
similarly had he done this like this the
simple check mechanism still applies and
if you ever interpose the king the Queen
all I have to do is this and your last
pawn is dead so white black is not going
to be that nice and put his king so far
away from your rooks where you can keep
checking him until you mating he's going
to go king c4 and now what does the same
idea work why not
no this is here so this is the starting
position check here check King see four
instead of King a for GA right so this
does not work because I simply Queen
check here check here check
oops no more mechanism yeah this is a
house about to say so the draw this
might already be lost for right
maybe I don't care that's not correct so
what now
and yeah you what to do what to do all
right Brooks III check let's give it a
try
King D for of course right I have to
keep the king attacking this this rook
yeah I cannot make him if he's in the
middle of the board so let's maybe try
to push him away how do I force this
no not so many choices here
the three charges can the king go to e4
no because I just take on d2 right so he
must go King c4 again I cannot take on
b2 because the rook is hanging I cannot
take on d2 because the other rookies
hanging I cannot move the King because
black is immediately threatening to
Queen and then the rook would be
helpless against the remaining pawn
okay King before and now a beautiful
point of domination the fact that Brooks
can weave maining attacks cops and
grandmaster games rather seldom but when
they do trust me that they will not miss
it rook c8 or rook c7 which one which
one here the correct move is Roxy Saavik
same idea but you will see why this
execution is exact
Roxy seven you must Queen and white
place what's the idea here well rugby
Seven Kings c4 and then after I take
your queen again you haven't gained
anything no no this is not the point
remember that we who are talking about
solar up c7 Queen now what
Ruby ate threatening checkmate in two
moves how many checks is black half here
none so he Quinton he does not have a
check on h7 because there's this root
perfectly placed
how do I play the other rook you would
have been there's a difference but let
me think about why there is a difference
I will figure it out oh yeah how do you
yeah I'll show the difference later
so here black White's idea is root being
a root k7 yeah so white black Queens
check here check only move to interpose
check here
tix my twins
notice how precise this has to be had
white done it the other way around and
played rook c8 be one Queen rook d7
black has the miraculous move Queenie
for controlling the b7 square from your
rook notice how in the main line this
route this Queen is helpless against
controlling neither b8 nor a7 a little
bit of a domination trick notice how
this would actually be a draw if this is
this pawn didn't exist because the Queen
could start checking my king so not that
hard right this is only a few moves
check your check here check your check
here check here
Roxy 7 B 1 D 8 and black and resign a
little bit of a interesting puzzle so
there's the kind of stuff that we do
let's try another one
this one is particularly ugly because it
seems like white
it's just enough just a little bit to
win this is something that's very useful
for long calculation and I'm going to
because you guys are beginning on this
I'm going to go move by move but when I
put this on master level students
I make them calculate everything from
this position and I don't allow them to
move the pieces because in a real game
you are that you're trying to see as far
away as possible without moving the
pieces correct so white is up a bishop
but unfortunately for him this is the
worst kind of bishop because it is well
known that a rook pawn that's the
incorrect color and a bishop is
insufficient to win right if blacks
Kings somehow makes it to h8 they gave
is immediately a draw so I need to be
able to come up with a plan that allows
my King to go all the way to g7 to help
me push the pawn and win or at least in
some way keep the King out of the way in
order for me to win so the cool thing
about this puzzle is that white already
has a lot of choices on move one he
could play h4 h3 Bishop h7 King f2 or
the bishop somewhere else and only one
of them wins now if you were 2,200 I
would probably just torture you and then
put this book put this puzzle on the
board and be like hey you got 30 minutes
but here we're going to try to apply
some a little bit of logic and see
what's going on so let's give it a
couple of tries here ok so the first
thing is what happens on the
straightforward approach right what's
the straightforward move here King f2
alright so we're going to calculate
super quickly if I play king of - he
plays king c7 and I take on f3 and he
goes king D 6 and I go King g4 he goes
king e5 right and I go King g5 already
his King is out of place right so let's
try that again 4
black king f2 king c7 King takes f3 king
d6 King g4 let's go to e7 alright sounds
like a good idea better idea right king
e7 King g5 right everybody follow the
Kings so after king g5 you can maybe
play something like king f7 and so I
don't think is going to go into g8 right
once he makes it to g8 it should be a
draw now so we have ideas now so at some
point play Bishop h7 and try to kick
that king out ah but now we have the
idea of just jettisoning the poem with
g6 so now we start to see that there's
actually a lot of subtleties to the
position right so Bishop h7 immediately
does not work because g5 here in g4 and
Oh we'll see
so King g3 King c7 takes here
h4 came back h5 King here h6 and the
pawn is just in time to distract the
bishop for a drop notice that if there
was no pawn here this is a win because
the King can be forced out of the h8
square right there is no pawn the king
can be zoomed out so f2 and now I have
to retreat my bishop which allows him to
play King g8 King and shade with a draw
everybody know that this rook pawn is a
draw right if there's a V okay so that
didn't work
let's striking f2 again if black plays
king c7 then I have several choices but
here I'm going to take advantage of the
fact that he doesn't have the move g4
and now do your mechanism and play
Bishop h7 now if I played King takes f3
the move g6 draws it's very simple
counting that the bishop that you cannot
actually reach the square right
Bishop takes g6 King d6 kingdom 47 King
g5 King f8 black is just in time
so no g6 sorry no King f3 and if Bishop
g6 trying to block away the squares from
the King he still has a draw because
here he's going to try to go to h6 where
he's going to get stalemated right so
King Bishop age 7 and then g5 gives him
another drawing mechanism even though in
this position I can take and pass on
this is a known draw after King g7 King
takes f3 all white all black all black
has to do is to keep shuffling around h8
and g7 and there's no way to make
progress because I'm going to stalemate
them if I bring my King too close and as
soon as I played my Bishop to g8 I can
swipe it off the board so that didn't
work so the correct way is king c7
Bishop h7 so now that late let's count
again King these 6 takes give me 6 mg 4
now if king f7 which is the best move
we're going to play the move King g5 the
point is to Zook swung the King out g6
King h6 g5 h 3 King f8 and now it seems
like it's almost a draw because if I
take on g5 he goes to g7 and achieves
extreme position but I have the move
King g6 now he cannot sacrifice its own
pawn because the G pawn is clearly
winning even though the H pot is not now
the king must move away which gives me
enough time to repeat the process but
now I have a free pawn winning
so black is going to be more subtle and
instead of king f2 king c7 he's going to
play g6 what does this work
take here h4 and now we're going to use
a very familiar mechanism to win the
game
kindiy 6 H 5 give me 7 H 6 f king f 6
only move to win in this position
there are two
if you push the porn kingi seven catches
and goes to h8 you cannot allow the King
into the dark square Bishop h5 and now
the King is absolutely sucks wand he
must move out of the way and then h7
leaves him outside the square right okay
me seven for example h7 it's game over
so instead he tries King f8 and here I
play Bishop not pawn bishop h7 the point
being that after king f7 takes King f6
what is just in time to prevent the King
from coming to g5 place King g4 King a4
I guess ahead of the variation and the
king will be forced outside the G file
pretty soon and then the pawn will
promote with ease not bad right not that
difficult but it is more difficult to
see it from this position because there
are a lot of nuances this variation is
not so long it's only eight or nine
moves long but it's very tricky in the
fact that the moves that you see are
very similar to each other but at the
same time they evolve very specific
ideas so this is a training exercise
alright see what else I have for you
guys aha so we're going to put all this
into a real game this is the game
between a verbeken bronstein from a
million years ago okay it says 2009 but
that was obviously not in 2009 and here
we have the position from what opening
probably a Sicilian and in the Sicilian
how would white lose the F part for the
D pawn they over get get traded where f4
and then taking where
so let's say at some point white plate
f4 and this point took what well imagine
the point there imagine respond right
here what could he have taken well okay
but let's say it's a white pot right now
right let's say that it was another nine
let's say was a white phone what could
he do this pawn huh yeah and he was
defending this pawn a deep pond was
played here and then defended so that's
how they got traded these are things
that we see so often then we're like all
is obvious but yeah I mean obviously
it's not so easy to see at this at the
beginning so here we're going to use our
imagination I think that you guys were
taught about imagination somewhere
around kindergarten and we're going to
put it to its best views here we're
going to try to see as far as possible
trying to see how all these ideas of
seeing far actually come completely into
the game of chess so our back is white
in this position and you thought about
the move Knight takes g7 oh my knight
takes g7
so after 1967 what do you think black
did he took it right because why not so
I was White's point you sacrifice a
piece you have to justify it how its
Pacific Lee alright let's look at Queen
h6 check right so Queen h6 only move is
King g8 if I play King h8 what happens
no no Bishop f6 more direct
all right good night takes you seven
king things jisub queen h6 check yeah
everybody follow this now there is no
King h8 why
you absolutely have to play to get but
why what's the difference yeah there's a
rope hanging on a fade right nobody's
defending that work on a fade everybody
see that yeah the real con afraid is
just hanging so you cannot actually play
King h8 you have to play King g8 so here
ever back is thinking how to bring in
the pieces if I play Bishop f6 you just
swipe set off the board so which pieces
can I bring in how do I do that
you could play rook f3 but unfortunately
it's very slow because after Bishop
takes Bishop Queen takes g5 King h8
black can always play the move f6 or
even better instead of playing King h8 I
can retreat my night from f4 to g6 and
that is sufficient for a win right I'm
up a piece so unfortunately not so good
to bring the routine to slow let's try
to break something else yeah
sorry II five is not going to move ah
so we get an idea right Ruka for pawn
takes f4 e five opening up the bishop
right
but unfortunately black can't just take
the bishop with this Knight
ah so now we continue the idea Bishop f6
alright Bishop f6 threatening technic
checkmate o g7 black absolutely has to
take this bishop but then you take with
the e pawn right so I'm still
threatening Queen g7 checkmate can black
stop it
there is no night enough for so how can
you stop it no way right but there is
still checks now I have to check kingi
one only move
what's another check knowledge three
check now if you play on takes h3 white
black has a very dangerous check which
one Queen c5 check right now if you go
to c4 Bishop c4 check and stop on
checkmate actually from white if you go
to h1 Bishop d5 check will end up in a
perpetual alright the King is way too
exposed so after nine h3 check do I have
another move King f1 alright how does
black check in that position Bishop c4
check looks very logical to me now how
can I cover 92 now black has to play
Bishop e2 check now can I take this and
the very least after Queen c2 check I'm
going to go back to g6 and prevent
checkmate right so I cannot take this
patient what does boy play King II won
now one more check for black
uh-huh and then white place and this is
exactly what happened in the game and
what I'm black recent so let's look at
what happened Knight takes g7 King takes
g7 actually the correct move is night C
takes D 3 after which the game would
have been a mess but then I wouldn't
have had this nice example to show you
guys so King takes to 7 Queen h6 sorry
rook takes f4 was most exact first but
arguably you could have played Queen e6
first take on f4 again 93 was correct
but we'll leave that for another
training session and now check King g8
forstride we already know what happened
to King in trade Bishop f6 if he 5 which
is the incorrect move order f5 and now
the Queen comes into the defense
so first Bishop f6 Bishop takes f6 d5 no
way to prevent this checkpoint except to
swipe the Bishop of the board now if
take eat 5 takes f6 no choice but to
start giving checks there is nothing
else check here check here check here if
rooky 1 sorry King e1 you get killed
after Queen e5 Queen g5 see how the
Queen comes to the defense and Europe
you're done way too much material so 92
forced check is forced cannot even think
about capturing this Bishop why black
has no more checks except Queen 85 check
and after before it is game over not bad
not bad for a little calculation and
this is what happened in the game
between our back and Braunstein a pretty
interesting combination that was
culminated by simple calculation this
was all calculated by white and then I
have to be guesswork it didn't have to
be what-ifs this was something that
white saw at the moment that he took on
g7 and this is more or less how
grandmasters calculate and this is how
grandmasters trained their calculation